I would argue that the second answer is best. The difference between the first
and the second is whether we print out a number or we return the number.
Returning a number is much more useful. If we return the number, then we can do
more computation with it. If we print it out, well, then it gets printed out and
it's hard to use for anything else. So, I'm going to assume that what we want to
do is the second choice. The third choice doesn't really match what was stated.
Maybe, we want the age in days, the third choice says, we'll give the age and
years, months, and days. Note that this answer depends on the assumption we have
about no time travel. We haven't described what that should be if the first date
is after the second date and we don't need to because we're going to assume that
could never happen. That the first date must always be the same or before the
second date.